the sustainance the clothes sustainance
of the human body in the human life
entirely depends of the system that runs
nature the entirely depends of the
systems that are working for the human
life and for the life of every living
thing and if that system is damaged well
the human being will perish because we
entirely depends from these things we
depend on word of with the pen up here
with the pen of food with the pen of the
space with the Pens of how the
environment is sound with the right
temperature with the right weather with
the right conditions for us to survive
and that's what the planet does for us
create the right conditions so we will
be in a harmonious environment and so if
we don't have that and so there there's
not going to be peace and there is not
going to be any reason to live in an
enjoyable life life will be crazy as
it's going that way pretty quickly and
live will be very confusing for most of
humans and it will be no longer life but
just surviving at all costs which will
become Magnusson insanity hello everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
Sakia very grateful to be on site at the
somatic sanctuary in Ojai in California
we are now going to be talking about
ancient wisdom we have mama who each one
joining us on the show hello hello thank
you thank you they were very very
grateful to have you I was very
fortunate to be introduced to you
teaching the ancient wisdom about last
month and since then I've been very
interested in continuing to learn and
embody this wisdom and we came down here
for the workshop that you had a two-day
workshop at the beautiful somatic
sanctuary and it was very powerful again
and I'm very grateful that you were
willing to sit down with us and I would
like to give some
background to those that don't know mama
Luigi Juan is a gifted native and
they--and maestro from Colombia
a master in bringing the ancestral
wisdom to all of America in the world he
is a vibrational healer holistic
educator Yogi and shaman of the light
he holds the unique distinction of being
the only mama born outside of Sierra
Nevada of Santa Marta Colombia
authentically ordained by the highest
ranking Kogi mama Jacinto who recognized
and tested him over a 15-year period and
was surprised to see how exceptionally
accurate mama Luigi Ron was in his way
of working with Aluna the spirit of the
mother mama has dedicated his entire
life to spiritual training and the work
needed to help transform people from all
walks of life to recover humans
righteous functioning as part of nature
on earth he has also been doing silent
service across the USA to
reharmonization spirits of nature here
in California and around the entire
country for 25 years and you can find
the links in the bio below to Cogan
Kisei where Luna foundation.org as well
as the Facebook page Cogan Casilla Luna
mama let's start things off by asking
you what is this ancient wisdom that you
are teaching the ancient wisdom of what
we call the original wisdom of the
mother the mother refers to the power
that has manifests everything into
creation from the spiritual dimension to
materiality and so the original living
wisdom of the mother is that that
originally was passed to the first
original ancestors the first spirits
sons and daughters of the mother in with
that the mother has established from the
very very beginning from millennia right
from the very beginning of the creation
has passed this ancestral wisdom that is
all about how to behave how to function
how to get along with each other as a
spirit and how to be able to co-create
and maintain the reality and which
we would like to live in essentially how
to get along with the environment that
sustain us especially in this dimension
and the human planet how we can really
function with nature which is
extraordinary basic and as ordinary
essential it's something that
unfortunately is forgotten the wisdom
that we're talking about is the wisdom
for the whole humanity is universal is
the origin of functioning as the origin
of the getting along is the origin of
holding harmony balance integrity in as
the original wisdom that really is
critical for maintenance space and
especially to preserve this planet
unfortunately that wisdom there is no is
not only for the indigenous our
dizziness people of the world not only
wisdom for the Kogi's of our my
ancestors the chip chest for the
ancestors of the Sierra Nevada the
Kogi's and others that original wisdom
the original wisdom of the earth is for
the entire humanity we are only son of
the groups that preserve it and we are
only son of the ones that is still a
practicing in applying it but it's not
that this regional wisdom is strange
integrations of the special for the
entire humanity when you see a Native
American people Americans or native
Africans of Native from any part of the
world when we look at them even if it's
a slight differences in a little bit of
controversial stuff they essentially
doing the same and when that wisdom is
lost which is the wisdom for the entire
humanity to behave in a beautiful
dimension and planning like this when
that is forgotten and undermined and
neglected we create what we had right
now a complete mess so this wisdom is
what we are here bringing
and telling the whole world especially
this is the mission that my mentor the
great mama
Jacinto put me to do and the we pioneer
15 years ago with him and bringing that
to the world because it was so critical
and it's so critical the the human being
recovered the original wisdom of the
earth to be able to function within this
environment and consciously responsible
for the planet one of the best ways I
think I've learned from you about
understanding this is what sustains us
it is the planet that we live on that
sustains us it is a nature that sustains
us every breath we take every drink of
water that we have every bite of food
that we have comes from this planet and
when we become disconnected from that we
see so many of the issues that have
arisen in our world I think that's a
beautiful aspect of this of this ancient
wisdom and like you indicated it's
ancient wisdom from all of the
indigenous tribes of pointing at the
same thing that we have in this case
lost I want to ask you about that
embodying that that remembering of what
sustains us of this ancient wisdom that
is the conscious living and functioning
the the the basis of the original wisdom
is very actually very self-evident and
extraordinary practical and functional
in the West the best ordinary proved of
the original wisdom is just the
functioning of the body if you see the
body has many organs many systems many
intelligent sturdy Nadia special
functions the very functions in a very
cohesive coordinated harmonious way even
though every organ can be doing a number
of functions they are developed for the
entire benefit of the whole system the
whole organized system the body shows
the house to work in unity
in harmony in imbalance so if the
organism that is functioning in unity
cohesiveness imbalance then nature will
come to them the same way well nature is
what nature is life works
people think that nature is trees and
rivers and all those are only the
material manifestation of the workings
of nature but nature is life force life
words is a conglomerated group of forces
coming from the cosmos in so forth and
so forth so the sustainance
the clothes sustainance of the human
body in the human life entirely depends
of the system that runs the nature the
entirely depends of the systems that are
working for the human life and for the
life of every living thing and if that
system is damaged well the human being
will perish because we entirely depends
from these things we depend on word of
with the pen up here with the pen of
food with the pen of the space with the
Pens of how the environment is sound
with the right temperature with the
right weather with the right conditions
for us to survive and that's what the
planet does for us create the right
conditions so we will be in a harmonious
environment and so if we don't have that
and so there the there's not going to be
peace and there is not going to be any
reason to live in an enjoyable life life
will be crazy as it's going that way
pretty quickly and I will be very
confusing for most of humans and it will
be no longer life but just surviving at
all costs which will become
Magnusson insanity if we destroy the
environment in which we live which is
lack of consciousness and conscious
responsible behavior so then we are all
compromising the most essential element
the human being and that's what this
original vision says if you don't
preserve harmony balance order peace and
sound environment the human being will
be crazy and that entirely depends from
nature we don't do that work give the
example of the body and how beautiful of
a cohesive system that is and if there
is an organ failure that happens well
the body is is injured in that process
and that is in a sense what is as part
of the systems these functioning systems
on the planet are experiencing these
injuries that the humans are not
functioning cohesively with nature with
the system that sustains them and now
you're indicating to us that it's it's
become like an allergic reaction of the
planet and that the amount of people
that are living in a non harmonious way
with nature is is so many that we now
how do we deal with the allergic
reaction that the planet is is giving us
right now we instead of to be part of
the harmony and and part of the very
harmonious functioning of nature nature
has give us the opportunity to embody
spirit our bodies are coming from the
workings of nature in a very an
extraordinary amazing way the body
itself is a piece of our and that is the
original reason of millennion the
original wisdom of the world and the
original reason of the human race is
right there in the body look at it and
you will care for that body you will do
whatever to preserve your life if
somebody comes to mess with your body
and touch it and even just do a little
pinch or something you will react and
you will act defensively what about if
we do the same with the system they have
provide our bodies and that's exactly
what we should do protect the
environment the mother our own lives and
bodies the provided of sustenance we
should protect
and we should do what is right in our
wisdom the wisdom of the ancestral land
Columbia
it is all about how to function how to
get along with the system that sustain
us the best relationship of the human
spirit should be with nature to begin
with otherwise his can you can now get
along with superior dimensions or
superior levels of consciousness of
celestial grounds or anything like that
we are here to master this perience in a
beautiful environment that was designed
for us to master consciousness to master
wisdom but we are doing the opposite in
in we - mmmm maybe matters worse we are
basically attacking our own mother
destroying it the damages that we are
causing to this planet are completely
out of proportions are extraordinary
unthinkable unconceivable the damages
that were causing to this planet cannot
be repaired prolly in millions of years
what nature took in time in process and
improvement for thousands and thousands
of years
we're disowned and in couple hundred
years and if we don't change our ways we
all ended up in a very catastrophic end
and I know alarming anybody but this is
the message it's coming to the point the
many people knows already that we are
already had passed the tipping point and
which is probably there is no way back
to recover to repair but we still can
stop becoming enemies of nature starving
in destroying our own mother the mother
and our own life the system that sustain
and provides for us this is this is
exactly for us what is insanity you know
and so this is the electric reaction
when the human beings becomes like a
pest there is like a new house if you
see some box around Sun in such as
explained before
well you're cool with it say yeah
especially if you are pro-life you know
kind of evasive you know your life you
know and you protect the play and that
is around there to answer yeah you say
well probably the father and the son and
then you said the whole Legion of ants
comes to you and then one night the
answer are you bet so you say no I had
to start spraying and so nature can
become very allergic in reactive to us
which is the case because we are
intruding invading destroying the organs
of functioning and recovery in their
organs of balance of the earth just to
make profits which is okay you know
there is there is level that it should
be intelligent and not blind to make
prophecy to make business but to the
point the people should respect it do
not cross the land in the line where we
already causing mr. dinelli damage that
is practically beyond repair
we should not cross that line and my
message here is also for the ones who
are making profits and destroying nature
I'm not gonna blame anybody because I
can point fingers to anybody but
remember that probably there also had
children and there are new generations
and monitors and guarantees the good
future or anybody what guarantees the
future of every single human being here
in a lower the status in a high class
his harmonic balance in his good
environment that is coming from nature
so I really I will really ask to these
people whoever is that they please we
beg you to reinvest the money that you
had take from nature to repair it please
do that please
you're not gonna do it because your own
set of the beliefs and you know system
of beliefs of your convictions and
everything but I'm telling people
they're still under speaking to the
people who still can call the level of
consciousness this is not about in what
side you are if you are in the right
side and the low side and the higher
side and the high class not is about the
called humanity that less remiss in
return to nature otherwise you will see
what happen and it's happening right now
it's not only what people is doing in
manipulating nature that's only another
consequence of the same same disaster
the disasters of the human races one
eight billion people that is
dysfunctional doesn't know how to get a
loan with nature including the ingenious
hats and the ingenious geniuses of the
planet with very few exceptions the
billions of years of evolution that it
took for the planet to be able to
sustain us and then in just a couple
hundred years the ways that in seems the
irreparable damages that been caused
need to be healed and like you requested
for those that have made profit off of
the planet and other humans to please
reinvest back into the nature that
sustains us to guarantee a better future
for us all and also I want to see what
you your thoughts are here you every
child being born in full connection with
the full potential to be connected to to
nature to spirit and then there is a lot
of deceptions and manipulations that can
for the fragmentation of the Spirit and
then who you please teach us about that
process yeah once
people is caught in an artificial system
that is actually is detected because
it's artificial
and it's also detected because it
doesn't get along with naturally if if
the system will get along with nature it
will be not that Detective and it will
not be that dysfunctional it's that
simple
but people has become so so desensitized
and so on sensitive and so on conscious
that the system of artificial
malfunctioning is completely predominant
in the human race is just moving in the
system that it dosing has any any level
of connection and in any level of
functioning with nature and so children
who is born in the same system unless
somebody come in bring the consciousness
because it's not to remove children from
dysfunctional system that's already
something really is it wrongdoer from
perspective is to bring children to come
and get along with nature so they will
be able the new generations by being
educated in their in the wisdom of the
world and the wisdom of functioning with
the systems that sustain us so they will
probably are the force that will create
the change very depends of the educator
who had a case educator and the
functioning with nature who probably the
ones who know the wisdom of the world
and the wisdom of the regional wisdom of
humanity that's exactly what we do and
so the question of deception is a system
that is completely artificial that has
no way to get along with nature he
proves that in this system
look another nast activist and now the
pro you know we say
rabble or something oh that's not what
we do we're not here to politicize or
utilize politics of politicizes fatality
that's completely stupid for us we only
follow reason and we tell people say
look if you if the Girona stop behaving
and building an artificial system we all
will be destroyed as simple as that
it has happened before it has completely
this behavior of being smart and trying
to outsmart nature with inventions with
technology with science is it's not the
first time the great civilizations have
completely been banished by the power of
creation because they they just went too
much little too far in their own you
know curiosity and their own stupidity
and they destroyed themselves will go in
the same way in stupid things trying to
destroy the system that actually sustain
us and then trying to outsmart the
system that is super intelligent and
it's also super super delicate they we
don't know how to do that and we all now
have the conviction that science and
technology is gonna repair the problems
that we create in the first place no
it's about the system of malfunctioning
if the system malfunction and it doesn't
get along with the system to sustain us
so then that's the catastrophic event of
a human being so the question of
deception is we want we are so convinced
this is exactly the deception we why we
are still so convinced that what we
doing it's just fine just because we are
barely sustaining it's a system of
malfunctioning that well it's okay in
somebody or soon you know very but if we
use group of people is benefiting from
that system that doesn't mean that the
system is not dysfunctional the system
and which is we're wrong is completely
dysfunctional
and as and is going to collapse whatever
it is this
functional and it doesn't is alone with
nature it will collapse simple as that
in soon in or later will collapse simple
as that and we don't want to prove that
the system is right through a very
catastrophic event the ultimate the
ultimate you know doom day you know boom
day you know like the ultimate ultimate
apocalyptic event - broke here our
system was wrong bye-bye everybody
this is exactly the deceptive the
deception lies in the fact that we in
season and sees it the way we operate
for centuries
especially the last century in this life
that that's a system the functions work
just because you know probably for some
work conveniently but that's no
guarantee they will not collapse so what
we're gonna void the collapsing of the
system that is dysfunctional and we
corrected it will be great for the ones
who are on top and good for the ones
that are law and we will continue the
deception lights in the fact that we
still completely freaking attached to
the system because he brings us profits
and benefits and pleasures and you know
power and all that but this is a
dysfunctional system completely it's no
wise that's why we're here that says
return to the original wisdom in safe
was dear for us is the planet the
functioning of the planet and let's get
along with it it doesn't matter if every
everybody's different in one different
things
nature is nothing but a very very big
variety of things and however nature no
matter how different is everything in
nature everything from the tiny to the
mighty works in harmony they are high
mountains
they have low balance and rivers in
caves and they function in harmony just
as Indy society high people with high
power with high money with high
sophisticated knowledge and information
there are low people that doesn't know
anything you know the tree has roots and
he has flowers and talk and instill in
nature everything functions cohesively
harmoniously this system can keep the
high ranking people and the low ranking
people but I still can function getting
alone that's the loss of nature of the
law the higher the lower should be the
stronger you know the stronger part
should be sustaining the whig part isn't
that the ways in nature
another opposite they wake and the
deficient sustaining the stronger it
will collapse a tree is not sustained by
the leaves and by the flowers trees
sustained by deep deep roots this system
pretend that the lover that the
whicker's sustained the stronger it will
collapse in its civilization is not
guaranteed
there have been collapses in the past
and the disconnection from nature and
immature playing with godlike
technologies is a recipe for disaster
and will you teach us about this
relationship I think this is a really
great way of explaining it that the
older brother carries this ancient
wisdom and that the younger brother is
out in the world creating anja nearing
building toying around and making all
these cool things but when the younger
brother is diskin
did from the ancient wisdom in doing
that it's again a recipe for disaster we
teach about that really completely the
the question of the younger brother and
elder brothers and younger brothers
he can't sue but a simple thing an elder
brother is an obedient brother somebody
who stood you know stick to the rules
follow the principles is rigorous is
reliable to the power as the beginning
has been in the jungle brother is a
jungle boy but is a teenager you know
like you know poison by ideas poison by
curiosity by rebellion by gray-gray
creativity's by bashes as crazy is very
drill as outgoing is just after
splitting in space matter broken down
the atoms and getting crazy building
buildings that are just thousands of
meters about so he can reach in his cars
the souls God and say hello look how
gray iron and all that that's the jungle
brother
yes tremendous ingenuity creativity
curiosity in been so kind of things that
are cool and sometimes are really
ingenious
he has also his own wisdom to keep going
his own life and everything but he went
crazy
so all their brother including us the
ones who call wisdom that we were born
in in any country that honors and
respect not nature most of us that are
from my generation we are completely
conscious in nature I was born as a
campesino as a country boy in a land
from the land from the way we live and
the nature is our mother and I in this
business of the spirituality ever since
I know myself the realest reality is
first you are the spirit nature this
life force that is a spirit you should
get along with or not with dignity with
respect like you respect your
grandmother bashang grandma
jungleboy put the great modern and
nursing homes and he go about since
entertainment and his inventions and
discoveries nothing here
the grandmother the grandmother dies in
the nursing home that's exactly the
disaster younger brother never learned
the wisdom from the ancestors from the
elders and that's why he goes about his
craziness and that creation is a
suspending like a pest like an infection
is pandemic and I will bring us to
destruction that will destroy the jungle
brother the entire planet it has
happened before because the mentality of
the jungle brothers which is not in the
mind that's not in the brain is in the
spirit this is curiosity in generosity
is he is thrilling instinct to discover
to find out to explain his ancestral sin
the spirit and he has caused already
many problems his own in this planet but
in dimensions and he said in different
times in the in the planet and the
cosmos the jungle brother has gotten got
some crazy and he has created all kind
of things but also I know saying there's
only jungle blood also they are their
brothers have been thrilled had been
enticed in seduced by the jungle
brothers attractions and he also had
felt that's what you see many of the
elders also fell into the same trap and
you can see here in America and other
places of the world there is no longer
real real people holding the original
living wisdom of the earth in humanity
and that's why people doesn't it's
completely forgotten with very few
exceptions so what do you spec about
that our race if it wasn't half but you
call the tutorial very clear I on top of
the younger brother he will get crazy
who lost sense of proportions will go so
mad and crazy then to the
on the destroys everything that's the
reason why I would come and tell what
we'll say and I'm been doing this for 50
years you know and Betty intensively
right now for the last 25 years look at
what is happening fortunately I gotta
tell that there is people who is getting
it
there's people probably like you there
are really a this is serious there's no
longer is stopped the game of McNees
destruction and unconsolable pleasing
stop it because it's time we're not
gonna have much time to repair right now
we can only stop incorrect we can we're
not going to correct anything because
it's probably not going to be time for
that the the conscious living that we
can embody for the process of healing
it's within us not outside of us and
outside of us is where we sometimes find
the deceptions the the entertainment and
the and the and the drugs and so many of
the things outside of us but on the
inside of us how do we heal from the
inside our connection to spirit in
nature and then how and then how do we
go out into the ancestral lands for
healing as well and go on that process
that there there are sacred spaces in
nature the spaces with the water system
with the rain system with the really
production of vitality and vitality in
the reproduction of all the bigger and
nature is repaired constantly in the
high mountains in caves in phantom
something on the ground currents of
water and caves and then Betty or Regina
rivers and there is no peaks in the ice
lands and all that in the gentle of
rivers in oceans and
in the oceans Lynch's is is repairing
and renovating nature is recreating
nature is recycling and everything if we
mess with those sites and we damage
those sites it's like in your body you
leave it it's damaged and then your
kidneys are damaged and then your
stomach is damaged and then you're lost
and damaged and then he becomes an in
systemic damage what do you think it
will happen what happened with that when
the whole body will collapse isn't it
probably would less so what were you
thinking that by causing all these
damages to the system of the world and
we're gonna repair it as stupidly run
and so the human being has been this
being disintegrated because it's
captivated by a system that is
dysfunctional and probably is not
intended that way but he went that way
for the lack of the other part the
wisdom that he tell you when it's enough
when enough is enough when you need to
stop to be in foolish thinking the
you're a genius the most foolish thing
in life is that you believe in you're
the genius when you are screwing
yourself and screwing many others that
is called the worst level of a stupidity
that's exactly what is happening in this
planet and then also and we can have
repaired we'll figure it out somebody
else will know the dimension and
unbalance I'm gonna tell you what to do
when it was simple from the beginning
keep them harmony keep the system
recycling in functioning do not damage
the structure of the planet energetic in
material structure to the planet don't
damage it so we will be able to receive
the forces of the cosmos and you don't
have to mess with anything else and you
can have a great life there with money
or without money but still
had a great life no but it's more than
money power and more than power is
domination and although really well that
way you have a hell because then you
start this one nature and this is a
sultan that they cause of disintegration
and the spirit that we were talking
about since inhuman has completely
forgotten the first is spirit and as
part of life force life force is spirit
so we don't care about anything that we
don't see we only care about what we can
see but they unseen visible the
supernatural that is not that
supernatural it's weird but doesn't mean
this is not natural and it's like every
single human being probably is weird to
himself because your fiercest spirit in
a body and the most essential thing in
your life is your spirit isn't it part
of life force but if you start
considering the your first spirit then
you say I'm getting crazy now you are
probably naturalized you lost the
natural sense of perceiving yourself as
a spirit and unfortunately people only
records the sense of the Spirit when
they're going to die I'm gonna die and a
dying bed and then you've rediscovered
something do you loss for the rest of
the beginning of your life on the entire
life you lost the sense of being the
spirit and then that is there to remind
you to prove you that you're the spirit
because something is living what is it
something is getting out something came
into the body to run the body to run the
life of the human and something it out
there for your spirit and so when you
lost sense of spirit you will lost sense
of consciousness when you lost sense of
consciousness you lost sense of
functioning and sense of purpose so
simple that's the wisdom and that's why
the human being is disintegrated now
when the spirit is not functioning with
the body her more
usually with a with a sense of purpose
then that's what people is wounded as
fragmented as fractured is afflicted
tormented because all of the Sun the
spirit doesn't has a chance and that's
why people is unconscious because
there's no spirit of presence and they
call it we call it the all kind of
practices and all kind things yeah those
of those things as bill that nice I
practice many spirit of things for most
of my life but the free spirit or
practices do you recognize that your
spirit directly and if you lost that
that's why people is unconscious where
there is no spirit that is not
consciousness how do we recognize that
we are a spirit it's so natural is that
Han like you recognize that flower and
then you see the flower right there do
you see an angel smell it
yes and so that roses the spirit body in
essence flower in essence that's exactly
the same thing that the human is his
body in his essence the flower is the
body the essence is the spirit they are
always together we lost that
consciousness
I say weight to support you healing that
will heal the dysfunctional systems that
are that we are just how we are
dysfunctional with nature right now and
then what would it look like then for us
to be at our full purpose because it
seems as though we have with this great
dysfunction many of us have a lack of
daily purpose daily meaning doing
something that we find very meaningful
every day so when we are fully embodied
with spirit then we're surrendered and
we get to achieve
our track of our divine purpose pilot
deception and the human reality which is
very actually discouraging and also the
cause of my city is that the purpose of
a life of a human being is not what the
Spirit has a grip on but it's the
purpose that the official system has
imposed upon him in the mind and in his
in his psychic and whatever it is not at
the spirit so the purpose of a life of a
human being is agree upon a new spirit
by the means of intelligent power
throughout a very very clear conscious
agreement with the power that has guided
us in the level into being as a spirit
we have a clear pure purpose and a
spirit that is completely forgotten and
it is not the same for every single
human being once again here is the body
the Lyra has a purpose to do 300 and
native functions in an astonishing way
probably more for the benefit of a
Tina's Laney something still the people
I wanna do my own thing but even if he's
daunting you poopers you should be for
the benefit of the whole for the benefit
of the collective as the body indicates
the heart does his own thing on his own
but with the purpose and the benefit of
the whole everybody can do something
as long as as far as is for the benefit
of the collective and the reason because
this when Braun is because that's the
notion of consciousness in the spirit
and that's the agreement to function for
the benefit of the whole there is no
suffrage but it went on because the
system of deception has imposed poppers
to the human being there is also the
official art the system is
it doesn't benefit their collective it
Bennett's the system but now the
collective simple it's a beautiful way
of looking at it all of the different
cells in the body like humans on the
planet how they all work cohesively in
the body for the functioning and if with
us on a civilizational level if they can
also work cohesively with their
individual purposes than in balance with
nature then that's that can be a
beautiful beautiful look you live in the
original living wisdom of humanity the
original living wisdom of the human race
the original pure wisdom of nature you
are every single instant as long as you
in a body as a spirit you are living in
on it the division which is keep the
valley alive it's not different that the
wisdom that runs in nature and runs the
entire system of nature you are there on
it it's the most ordinary proved the
functioning in the life of the body
there you go and then you asking what is
the wisdom is not in the books is not in
the you know data and the collection of
misinformation the wisdom of this planet
this dimension which is the reflection
of a celestial original vision of the
Spirit is right there in your body and
the Spirit is coming to work with it as
it's coming to work in nature and people
is completely unconscious when they have
health issues and real serious diseases
and challenges now they see that the
body doesn't functions and then probably
the spirit gets completely disintegrated
now they have a problem and that's
probably the only time that they pay
attention you know
couple other thoughts on the way out I
went out I want to hear your thoughts on
this so when we when we tap into the
cohesion of of being connected to nature
on a moment-to-moment basis we feel
expansive we feel beyond we feel all
that it is we feel mother we feel the
source the spirit and if we can hold
that on a moment-to-moment basis a we
you said that that was grace yesterday
you said that was grace if you can
connect with grace on a moment-to-moment
basis then that can be one of the best
ways to live consciously and function
consciously the first estimate of the
state of grace is they do a spirit as
part of that perfection we are part of
the mother power of part of the part of
God in the spirit we are part of that we
were born and created as a part of God
and that's the first level of grace if
you're conscious that you're part of the
power of grace so then your
consciousness will be recovered son of
the many suite of practices of this
world especially in the younger brother
they supposedly are pointing out to it
but jet people doesn't change their own
behavior when they discovered and they
have this direct very simple natural
experience the you are the spirit part
of the great great great power the new
behavior will be completely changed and
that's exactly the digital wisdom since
probably people has gone so far away
from the power and we did not follow the
most important law of functioning which
is reciprocity reciprocity means to
correspond one and another in a loving
Association you call love miss
reciprocity
if we don't reciprocate with the power
and has created us we called the mother
power we have to correspond with the
mother power the first level the way we
corresponds to the mother power is
fulfilling agreement that we came here
to fulfill and obeying the natural law
of function and created by it we did not
create the laws with the now created
principles of function and they were
created with the creation itself if we
will loss how to correspond with the
power naturally functionally where we
will not function with everything we
don't correspond with anything we take
we take to take the Technic we don't
care
therefore the natural law the original
law of reciprocity is the power the
wholes harmony integrity and balance if
you don't reciprocate with everything
and then things will collapse just like
would you have enough relationship with
somebody you give give and give love or
you take and you take and you take and
take the so-called love in the
relationship but you don't get back what
kind of relationship is that the real
relationship between humans between
nature between power the power of
creation that we called the mother our
Essbase and reciprocity you take you
give back in every possible way is that
what we do we have a disposable planet
mentality yeah we use in abuse and then
we dispose it's certainly not even
conscious and irresponsible and there's
big delinquencies you use this word that
we have to pay our taxes that were
delinquent on the taxes as
the connection to nature that we've been
disconnected from fragmented from well
the the taxi thing in his translated
into the jungle brother terminology to
make that know that weird more connected
with the dysfunctional system the fallow
which is the monetary system the
financial system the money system is
like Yap
paid the taxes to the ones who you know
are the organized system of finances and
supposedly the system that runs the
budget for everything to maintain
everything but is to maintain a system
it's not to maintain nature so the
system of monetary financial staff it
will be great if the part of the budget
is in best to repaired natural in to
maintain natural so in other words paid
the taxes to nature the same pay the
same way to pay taxes for everything
it's great that you pay taxes because
part of you know the collaboration and
then the great part for maintenance
system there is necessary for humans
absolutely
but part of that budget should be
dedicated to the pediment in nature
because most of the profits in models
most of the business and most of the
money's make out of using abuse in
nature and destroy nature and
exterminated nature so why now part of
those things should be invest in
repairing nature this very intelligent
actually it was a concerning but against
anybody release inconvenient but just
for a while if you people get used to
pay taxes for everything or taxes well
that's amazing is good because in
maintenance system but it's not
maintained the system they maintain that
system that depends out of it in that
system that is closed the system that
really sustain us pay the taxes to
nature the same way you paid the taxes
for everything and then we will be in
balance why a little and stop
the crazy destruction the work created
if we paid taxes to nature in many
various ways versus maintained
maintenance look at this if you have a
little machine the lawn machine - called
the lawn and keep it beautiful it needs
maintenance in insta bait the handyman
the operators and everything else in it
so what's the kind of money that we
invest in maintains natural if we were
taking everything from nature what's the
kind of work was the kind of investment
that we do and workers in labor and
humans that are completely dedicated it
should be a department in this country
and in many others that Department and
nature maintenance in billions should be
invest in it and cool
continue with your business but you also
are investing in maintain and repair in
nature the same thing that you do with
your refrigerators with your computers
we use sophisticated cars and planes and
quantum computers do it with nature and
then things will be better I wrote this
down in the notes during the workshop
that it would be interesting if 10% of
every single a venture capital fund over
ten million dollars had to go to 10% of
it had to go towards this maintenance of
nature budget around the world I think
that would be very helpful things like
that also when you say pay your taxes
you're making it clear you're not going
to the ocean
unconsciously taking a selfie and then
leaving this is a go there it's not a
selfie is selfish
you got the natural food you attractive
face take the pictures probably before
committing suicide you know because I
hasn't been the case in a beautiful
setting in nature and you go that's
what's so wrong with us that's the title
of - coming book oh what's wrong with us
this is a level of insanity what's wrong
with us I mean could you bother to just
give a little respect to the grandmother
and say grandma how you doing I love you
it's ridiculous to be there or we can
only have sex there and then call kind
of ways and get naked and get bitten by
jars or something like that us and then
they're selfish before committing
suicide what's wrong with us
nature is there to be honored to be
respect not to be only using abuse and
in a society like this one of the most
powerful and yet cynical empathetic and
beautiful world is word in language in
its use in abuse more than any is abuse
that word is exploding and so so so so
so so many ways with animals in
relationships with with everything
verbal abuse psychological abuse sexual
abuse all kind of abuses which is our
level zone that might be true but what
about the abuse to nature nobody says
anything about the abusive nature I've
used to the assistant to the grandmother
model earth that sustains us all what
about the abuse the collective global
abuse the biggest biggest abuse of all
what you don't say anything about it we
do we are abusing nature we are
exterminating nature of the system that
sustain us because of the lack of
consciousness the lack of responsible
behavior and because we have lost sense
of the spirit sense of being and sense
of functioning in the last thing I think
I would love for you to touch on quickly
is on a big picture level of what's
happening on the planet
it is in many ways seems at times that
there are forces that are at play on
this beautiful planet that are beyond
what is here in the physical world and
so what is it and sometimes it literally
feels like light forces versus dark
forces that are at play on the planet
and where do they come from how are they
do the dark forces come within that
spiritual fragmentation when we're
fragmented disconnected from nature
that's where evil comes in teach us
about that there's feet of fragmentation
the first level is the loss of sense of
spirit and then let's say shocking is a
parable experiences that because of non
knowing and no holding our such as a
spirit just just the characters and
personalities no sense of spirit
whatsoever so that in itself grace of
serious serious representation in the
spirit the Spirit is our inability to
come in and perform is real real
function so that from intention causes
the others you know though this is that
because we don't operate as a spirit
consciously then we were start creating
two levels of energy so levels of
quality in an hour and development which
is lowest levels of energy intensity
which is coming from mentalizing and
mentalizing then the lowest kind of
energy is created by humans is
mentalizing
psyching things out like crazy I'm using
mentalizing and I'm using psyching out
you know especially with experts the
mental eyes overanalyze they cannot be
natural anymore have some sense of
proportion and common sense that is the
most common sense from nature we are the
spirit life versus the spirit and so
when we had lost senses
sense of being and sense of function
with nature you know so then everything
gets crazy and we create a dense
operating way that probably attracts the
same from other planes run over the
spaces from other dimensions and then as
that is degrading integrated even more
probably attacks the attracts and
magnetizes something you can call that
forces at place forces of evil forces of
that part yeah but we're calling for it
we are the ones responsible that lady
will be there in some function God put
evil is there to do some function what
we do we wouldn't do ours that it should
be intelligent and divine no evil is
there for the poopers who knows the
Bible says and some of the cons of the
Bible and your wisdom the wisdom of the
of the most of the Christian world and
so knowledge they say that God creates
evil for the poopers release to
progressively we're faithful in
conscious you know if we are integrated
in function intelligent intelligence is
part presence of spirit if we were the
super probably what attracting that he
will take control of us and sabotages
and manipulate us into some way it's
totally up to us we are the ones who
bring the problem we are the ones who
can solve the problem with wisdom with
with consciousness and with
responsibility we will solve the even in
at the time so we're living in critical
times and the times that are completely
crazy despaired in confusion we can come
to senses we can come to terms everybody
with the song capabilities and Gibson
wisdom and stop the problem if we cannot
appear fully at least we can correct and
bring a
let's called future for the new
generations this is exactly with the
ancient wisdom of my ancestors it's
necessary in this world of the jungle
brother the jungle brother has to stop
being naughty in being spoil in can to
visit the grandmother and receive some
consoling no only with the psychology
but with the grandmother wisdom wow this
has been definitely one of my favourite
sit-downs I've ever had on the show
thank you so much today I said thank you
for having me thank you thank you
everybody
we're very very grateful for you and
then one moment I'll close the show
quickly I just want to say everyone
please please please do check out the
links in the bio below to the Kogan
Kashiwa Luna foundation org as well as
the Facebook page the amount of times
that you're traveling around the United
States there's a Nashville in Florida in
the California and Colombia so please
there are there are plenty of
opportunities to come and partake in
this ancient wisdom and we highly highly
recommend you do so there's also other
videos as well of mama giving talks
online so please do check those out and
share this type of ancient wisdom with
your friends your families co-workers
people online share this and go and pay
the taxes to the ancient mother took our
grandmother to a source to spirit to
what sustains us thank you very much for
tuning and we greatly appreciate it and
we will see you soon thank you thank you
so much